bakaye traoré journaliste spécialiste du
mali chez du sahel directeur de
publication du site maliko info bonjour
et merci d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france quel regard portez-vous sur la
réponse apportée par la cdo au coude et
au mali mais je pense que la réponse
apportée par la cia aux est une réponse
à la fois équilibrée mais aussi réaliste
comme vous le savez bien cette décision
de la cedeao envisage donc une sanction
de six tendre le mali au niveau des
instances de la cedeao la cedeao n'a pas
voulu aider prendre des sanctions
d'ordre économique etc qui scellait
vraiment quelque chose de grave par
rapport au mali parce que vous savez le
mali est un pays enclavé et donc ceux ci
avaient eu des actions d'ordre
économique cela est bien posé d'énormes
problèmes par rapport aux matinées de 6
par rapport aux pays voisins dont les
économies dépendent aussi également été
par le mali donc je pense que cette
décision de la cedeao et équilibrée dans
ce sens et réaliste parce que la
décision de la cedeao est bien confirmée
c'était la décision à faire la décision
qui a été prise par le haut
la cour constitutionnelle d'humalys
d'allier la confirmation de libé de
monsieur assi me guettait président donc
de la transition mais aussi la cedeao a
suggéré nous sinon imposer enfin le
profil civile d'un premier ministre mais
ce qui était déjà la décision adoptée
par le président de la transition a ses
mérites à le choisir 1,1 prémisse
d'ailleurs tissu durant le mouvement qui
a conduit donc à la chute du régime
moubarak et a donc pour qu'on comprenne
bien quelles incidences ça peut avoir
sur le mal et à sa suspension les
institutions de la cedeao très
concrètement je pense que c'est c'est un
peu
nos politiques institutionnelles
autrement dit les autorités de la
transition ne l'ont pas à siéger aux
instances donc au de la cedeao
tous deux l'ont donc de restes de la
transition mais je pense que ça n'a pas
tellement d'impact par rapport à la
conduite de la transition dès lors que
les décisions seront prises par les
autorités de la transition à l'antenne
et non des sanctions économiques et qui
pouvaient tomber sur le mali et je pense
que de manière réduite est beaucoup plus
et beaucoup de manières et douter
beaucoup plus des sanctions d'ordre
économique plutôt que des actions
diplomatiques en août dernier dans la
foulée d'un premier coup d'état
militaire la cedeao avait infligé au
mali un embargo commercial et financier
hier la cedeao en a écarté de telles
sanctions elle ne dit rien de l'arrêt de
la cour constitutionnelle qui fait donc
un des singles tard le président ne
réclame pas non plus le rétablissement
dans ses fonctions de l'ancien président
de transition
très concrètement la cedeao a conforté
finalement oui hier le colonel keïta oui
à mon avis cette décision donc de la
cedeao a en quelque sorte apporter une
certaine légitimité je dirais par
rapport à la décision de la cour
constitutionnelle qui a confirmé à
simonetta président donc de la
transition en quelque sorte
est-ce que la cedeao avait une autre
alternative ou une autre au march
madness
je ne pense pas et c'est pour quand j'ai
parlé d'un peu de réalisme politique et
je pense que ça ça a permis en quelque
sorte la cedeao de ne pas perdre la face
parce qu'il faut rappeler que l'as la
sanction de l'acid house - du premier
coup d'état du 18 août et la sanction
c'était d'imposer une sanction
économique
au nom donc de la continuité de la
transition sous la présidence de choses
d'un civil en l'occurrence ben dhaou qui
dirigeait la tradition et on a vu que
malheureusement cette solution d'avoir
un président civil à côté avec un
vice-président militaires qui ont fait
le putsch et ça n'a pas marché pendant
neuf mois le pays est resté à boulot et
aucune des réformes majeures qui sont
attendus n'ont pas eu lieu
eh bien on est toujours très élevé il
tourne un peu en rond et donc capté par
la cedeao a pris note de l'échec de
cette première solution envisagée cette
deuxième solution qui a aidé avoir
commencé par une décision de la
compétition au plan interne et au plan
sous-régional contient 4 5 vous
légitimez cette décision de la cour
constitionnelle encore puma racing et à
président de la transition
sa facilité les choses je pense au plan
sous régional mais aussi au plan interne
ça va le conforter les autorités de la
région pour continuer la suite et malgré
tout le mal et se retrouve de plus en
plus isolé sur la scène internationale
quels risques concrètement pour le payer
je pense notamment à la mise en garde
hier d' emmanuel macron qui menace de
retirer ses troupes françaises
mais attention quand vous lisez bien la
déclaration de la déclaration finale de
la cedeao la cedeao invite les
partenaires du mali notamment dû
sûrement ses partenaires comme
l'international d'accompagner le mali
dans cette transition
mais tout en demandant aux autorités de
la transition des faire en sorte que le
cap des 18 mois ne soit pas dépasser
afin que des élections aient lieu en
février 2018 ou un président
démocratiquement élu possible et je
pense que mâcon qui a fait cette
déclaration de menace sont beaucoup
s'étaient déclarés démarre quand je
pense à comme beaucoup plus solide et
menace à la bei donc de la rencontre de
la cdo afin que les autorités de la
cedeao puisse envisager des sanctions ou
mettre des pressions en tout cas sur les
autorités de la transition pour qu il
puisse y avoir vraiment un président
civil
mais je pense que cette déclaration de
la pensée beaucoup plus une menace pitot
qui nous voulons des politiques de se
retirer d'eux du mali tout le monde sait
qu'aujourd'hui le mali et ses
partenaires barca depuis la milice mans
sont tous dans le même bateau contre le
terrorisme et tout le monde sait que
aujourd'hui et même une grande puissance
france etats unis autre ne peut pas
faire face
seul pas socialisme et au terrorisme qui
sévit dans les sédunois d'origine
aujourd'hui est donc aussi la france à
travers son président annonce le rétais
de barkan je pense que c'était beaucoup
plus une menace et je pense que la
situation est telle qu'aujourd'hui la
france n'est pas seule est-il du jour au
lendemain du sahel merci beaucoup pour
votre regard bakary traoré je rappelle
que vous êtes un journaliste spécialiste
du mali et du sahel directeur de
publication du site malécot info